So the blue fairy shows up,
so that's nature.
So what I'm saying is that nature will
cut kids a break if you think of nature
in the guise of,
well their mother for example,
but even the biology of other people,
because we're wired to accept behavior
from children that we wouldn't accept
from other people.
So nature will forgive.
So she shows up in your heavenly guys
and says what's going on?
And Pinocchio again,
because he's naive,
but also because he's not good.
He's not evil either.
He's,
he's neither or both.
It depends on how you look at it.
And he also has no idea how smart he is
and how smart he isn't or how smart the
person he's talking to his.
And uh,
instead of admitting what he's done,
he lies about it.
And that's interesting because it does
suggest that he understands at some
level that he set himself up for this
because you know,
he could just say,
you could have just told the truth,
this horrible Fox kidnap me and sold me
to this slave holder.
Which is true.
It's a lot more true than the story he
tells.
He tells a story about some monster,
you know,
a fictional monster.
He coulda told even three quarters of
the truth and how to work,
but he doesn't.
He just obscures the story entirely and
this is the part of the movie that
people remember and I'd edited this out
for years when I was talking about this
movie.
I forgot what it was so significant.
His nose grows right and it grows too
ridiculous length.
And why is that?
I think it was Mark Twain,
Samuel Clemens,
I think who said,
one of the advantages to telling the
truth is that you don't have to remember
what you said and that God that's worth
listening to because.
So there's a bunch of things I've
learned as a clinician and one of them
is because you're often in really weird
situations with people if you're a
clinician because things happen that
don't happen normally and you don't know
what to do.
And so what I've learned is I just say
what I just say,
what's happening,
whatever it is,
regardless of what it is,
you know,
I'll just try to describe it as
accurately as I can and not worry about
in some sense,
not worried about the consequences,
you know,
like I'm not going out of my way to
cause trouble.
But if you're in a really,
and I'm telling you,
this can save your life at times,
especially if you're dealing with
someone who's paranoid,
who's really paranoid,
you do not lie to someone who's paranoid
and violent.
Because as soon as you lie,
you're aligned with the forces that are
persecuting them and they're going to be
war because paranoid it makes people
hypervigilant,
like they're on amphetamines.
In fact,
you can make people paranoid by giving
them enough and fed felonies and you can
make paranoid people more paranoid by
giving them amphetamines.
So they're hypervigilant because they
feel that everything is predatory and
against them.
And so they're watching you like you
would not believe way more than you're
watching them.
And if you flicker ally while you're
talking to them and they're really on
the edge,
you,
you're done.
So it's what's one thing to really know
if you're ever in a really bad situation
and you don't know what to do,
you tell the truth.
Minimally you don't disclose too much.
That's just another lie.
You tell the truth minimally and
carefully and hopefully,
and you might get out of it,
you might get out of it,
but if you falsify it,
look the hell out.
So the truth is a real.
It's a real mechanism of protection in
dangerous situations,
you know?
So if someone's trying to intimidate you
and you,
you think they might get violent that
they asked you if you're afraid,
then you tell them that you're terrified
and that you hope that things will go
okay.
Or you say,
I'll give you an example.
One time I was in an airport and uh,
we're in this lineup to fly back to
Canada that said international flights.
And so as long line up like 50 people
and we got it,
I got about three from the front.
It was still like 40 people behind me
and the guy behind the counter decided
that he was just going to shut down the
line and that we could all go to this
other line,
which was like 300 people long and I
suggested that he not do that because
we'd been standing there for half an
hour and that he could just deal with
the 20 of us that were last and and like
have a clue.
So he called the sheriff right away and
this was down in Florida and it wasn't
that long after nine slash 11.
And so these guys came up and they were
armed and they came and said,
looked at me because of course he told
them that I was causing trouble,
which I wasn't.
I was just trying to not
left.
What would you say?
An arrogant bureaucratic scum rat take
advantage of me.
So which is not the same as causing
trouble.
So anyways,
as soon as the cops came up,
I said,
look,
I'm going to do exactly what you tell me
to do right now and I'm not going to
cause any trouble,
but I would like you to hear what
actually happened.
And so that,
that's a good example of a situation
like that.
It's like if someone's got,
you know,
Bravo Bravado,
it's a very bad idea and I was going to
do exactly what they told me because you
know,
they didn't know who I was and I didn't
know what they had been told.
So anyhow,
the problem with lying is that it's a
hydro and kids find this out very early
[inaudible].
You tell one lie and what happens is it
has one of the consequences that you
expect.
Maybe you get away with it,
but it has three or four others that you
don't expect.
And so it's like it grows some,
some complexity and then you have to
tack a lie on each of those little
complexity outcrops.
And then they grow three more
complexities and soon this little light
turns into great big ball of lies.
And at some point it becomes painfully
evident to everyone,
and by that time you're in such,
you see this with politicians like that
guy who was sexting with Anthony Wiener.
Yeah.
Perfect name for him,
man.
It's so funny.
Uh,
I shouldn't make that comment because
it's so obvious,
but it's still funny,
but you know,
he,
that's exactly what happened to him.
It's like,
it wasn't even so much the event
because,
you know,
people are stupid,
they make mistakes.
And actually the public is somewhat
forgiving if you say,
yeah,
Jesus,
I'm a real moron and you know,
like really seriously,
how could I do that?
But I did.
And like I'll try not to do it again.
But what happens with politicians is,
and I'm not speaking specifically of
politicians,
is they'll make an error and it gets
exposed and then they make three others
trying to cover it up with Nixon for
example.
And then the whole thing just turns into
a complete scandal.
And maybe they could have got out of it
at the beginning by just telling the
truth.
It's like,
yes,
I'm an idiot.
You know,
I'll try not to do it again.
Well,
that isn't what happens in this case in
Pinocchio grows this elaborate series of
lies and the ferry is willing to be a
little generous to him because he's
little and cute and he's still a puppet
and she tells him not to do that and
that she's going to give them a pass
this time,
but that she isn't going to be able to
intervene on his behalf.
Again.